what's going on everybody welcome to
another Python basics tutorial video in
this video we're going to be talking
about is eval evil is @a eval is
actually built in function to Python so
you won't actually need to import
anything so what is eval eval is
literally short for evaluates and so
what it does is it evaluates any
expression that you pass through it in
the form of a string and it will return
the value ok so you pass through an
expression so you can't pass through a
definition so you'll see what I mean in
a little bit when we kind of pull this
out but why might you actually want to
do something like this well sometimes
you'll you'll find yourself in position
where maybe you're parsing something off
the internet or something basically
you're you end up with a list but it's
in a string form so then you have to
take that list maybe and split it by
comma space or something like that but
maybe you've got something a little more
complicated and or what if it's like a
Python dictionary what if you had a
Python dictionary in you in string form
but you wanted it out or sometimes
people might even want to save the
string version of a dictionary and then
later loaded into memory obviously the
better solution there would be pickle
but nonetheless you might find yourself
in this situation first of all we could
say for example let's let's just say
list STR for list string equals
literally it's just going to be a string
but it's going to be a list
okay so just populate that with whatever
you want now so we had this list that is
a string but then what we could do is
say list underscore string equals eval
list string and now we can print a list
string but also lets up print list
string no we don't have that many
elements to alright save and run that
and sure enough we load in the list and
now it is actually a Python list and
then also we're able to access elements
of the second element
the second element this would be the
zero with first at second perfect so
that's an example of of eval now what
else might we be able to do so we could
go like this we could say we could say
something like X equals input um let's
say I don't know X equals input and in
fact actually what we'll do is we'll say
x equals eval input code all right and
then in fact we'll also do x equals
input code and then this will be check
this out
okay so first we'll just let's just run
this and this is the first X so let's
say let's do print hi nothing really
happened now we're on the check this out
version and we're going to do print hi
and would you know what let happen we
printed hi so we were able to actually
run a function but could we could we I
define a function or even anything so
let's just put X there let's say x
equals 5 we can't do that okay so you
can't evaluate a definition right you
evaluate an expression so what if we did
this what if we said let me move this up
what if we sales say nothing for there a
5 less than 10 okay oh well hold on
let's go here let's say print
check this out
five less than ten and now we get it
true so again this is an expression so
we can do anything like that with a vow
now that's a vow and now we're going to
graduate on in the next video to what's
called exec which is short for execute
now execute can do basically everything
a valve does and a little bit more so
exec is going to compile and evaluate
the codes so this means we actually
could define functions and and we could
do this as well so naturally exec is
probably the most dangerous of all of
these especially if you're letting
dynamic variables that users could
submit in some form or fashion into exec
but anyway still a cool thing to know so
we're going to cover that in the next
video if you have any questions or
comments on this video please feel free
to leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time